foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah I didn't know like we didn't know
if anybody was in here so he was
checking to see if anybody was in here
says I don't want to be like talking to
nobody you're starting to come in okay
that's good there's like four or five
they're coming in now so yeah it's a
haunting Mondays again I apologize for
us not doing a movie or yesterday we
just didn't have time to watch the movie
and I felt she's getting overpassing I
mean I feel much better today I didn't
feel great this morning like I felt kind
of pukey and like [__] but then
um I took some cold medicine and I was
all right so I feel a lot better now
it's a little I have a little bit of
cough but it'll be better by the end of
the week yeah yeah it'll be fine it'll
be fine but uh yeah so we did watch an
episode of dancing last night and again
I'm trying to get I'm trying to go and
kind of get all the all the ones in the
first four seasons that we haven't
covered as I mentioned before I like
this one I forgot all about I did
see about it but then I was watching it
and I was like oh yeah I remember this
and I remember these people and [__]
like that and this was actually like a
really good episode like it was like
pretty creepy you know what I mean yeah
and it had some good special effects in
it and it had some good uh spiritual
angles of helping ghosts go cross over
to the other side kind of like something
out of The Frighteners it was pretty
good it was good to show the ghost ghost
was Ghost was telling his wife and his
daughter to shut up not listen to what
the psychic was saying and he was trying
to help him go on to the other side
he kind of yeah the ghost was uh kind of
a dick yeah
the story that they use in this is that
it was uh
dude molest and his daughter and the
daughter told the mom the mom's not like
is it true you know and they're back in
the 50s and driving the car and he's
like what are you gonna do about it she
pulls the wheel and kills everybody in
the car she's like that's what I'm gonna
do [__] I ain't playing right
nah I don't know if there's any any
historical data to back any of this up
uh yeah but it happened it had to do
with a look like a motorcycle and a car
wreck and a motor it was like a
motorcycle wreck that involved a car out
in front of somebody's front yard which
woke this Spirit these spirits up yeah
even though the two accidents were like
unrelated yeah they were unrelated yeah
hence why they call it the Awakening I
guess the Awakening yeah yeah
I'm gonna [__] make all kinds of
I don't know what yeah it's like one
once that is Anthony call still alive
like the narrator the enclosening
[Laughter]
who's that because because you can do
you could do voiceovers for paranormal
yes yeah you know what I mean oh yeah I
think that's right yeah you'd have a
great time yeah especially drinking well
yeah you just like say there in the
audio Booth I had to have you with some
tequila yeah you'd have to have me
[__] you'd have to get you laughing
though
you'd have to [__] talk me over there
the enclosing The Awakening the Devil's
Child
see there you go yeah
I have to say there was actually a quite
decent horror movie called The Awakening
uh that had Rebecca Hall in it that came
out back in
I want to say it was 2011 or 2014 or
something like that but it was really
good it was kind of like an old school
ghost story didn't love the end but
um it was good otherwise
Hugo said hello guys Jenny hope you're
feeling better yes I actually do feel
much better today I'm still not 100 but
I feel like about 100 times better than
I did yesterday I just well I felt like
complete ass yesterday
and I don't usually get sick I think it
was just because
I don't know I guess it was just because
I was tired and I hadn't had much sleep
and
like you know all the stress and
everything like that of like all the
driving and all that kind of stuff so
maybe my immune system was suppressed or
something because I don't normally don't
get uh colds I have no idea if any
notifications of the [__] live stream
camera sent out
because there's because there's nobody
here there's hardly anybody in here
kind of spotty with notifications well
the thing about it though is that we do
it at the same time like every Monday so
you think that like if you were really
hardcore they would know about it all
right well let's just go ahead and get
into the case then yeah uh so yeah so
this was from season four uh episode two
as I mentioned called The Awakening I
have to say that the people that were in
this one like the husband and wife they
seemed pretty credible like they didn't
really seem and they were both cops yeah
or they both worked for the police
department they both worked in law
enforcement
so I kind of feel like maybe
I don't know particularly the woman she
seemed very level-headed so and even
though some of the stuff that happens in
this episode is kind of crazy
um I don't know I I'm not I don't really
think she was making it up you know yeah
she didn't seem like she was making it
up no it seems it seems sincere to me
yeah something happened because some of
the people on here you're just kind of
like really yeah okay but like these two
seemed like they were pretty down to
earth you know what I mean yeah and and
so did the the psychic he didn't seem as
out there as like so yeah he wasn't
super flaky like some of the other ones
he seemed like he seems like a working
class you know what I mean
which I thought was kind of nice we kind
of came across a little bit more like a
parapsychologist yeah yeah yeah not like
kind of the spiritual angle yeah not
like some of it's like new age kind of
he didn't right across like that hand me
my crystals
put salt around some [__] ghosts can
walk through a wall but it can't walk
that's the rules yeah rules if you
believe that I just made up maybe if you
believe in the rules the ghost has to
believe in the rules too
maybe so but not my experience
you know not really no I mean that would
be pretty lame if like yeah you get to
be a ghost you're like awesome I'm a
ghost and then it's like what I can't
walk through assault yeah like that's
some [__] right yeah and it's even
worse because I can't walk through the
soul because this dude thinks I can't
walk through the salt
like yeah I don't like that yeah that's
pretty bad I don't like that I'm a ghost
I can do whatever the [__] I want right
what I'm saying right that's kind of the
whole fun of being a ghost yeah I think
that's some silly [__] it's kind of like
just kind of like a damn Chinese vampire
that Chinese vampire can like walking a
straight line and it has to hop and yeah
yeah Chinese vampires hop in case yeah
there's even all like a lot of those uh
horror movies from back in the day like
the 60s and 70s had the hopping vampires
and stuff which is always like very
funny to watch the audiences
um but that's just part of the folklore
I don't know I don't really know like
why
uh where that came from maybe because
their legs were tied together because
they were like mummies oh yeah maybe
maybe something like that I think some
of them only had like one nostril too
where did I where the [__] did I read
that I don't know I could totally be
pulling that out of my ass but I know I
read that somewhere
but I think it was like because I was
just like that's funny specific all
right
so yeah so the couple at the center of
this are named Marcy and Randy I think
they said Wyckoff right I think that was
what their last name was I read it I
wasn't sure if I spelled it right but I
think that's what they said because it
that we have all the all the shows on
DVD but none of them have closed
captioning
yeah I'm just like way to say hey [__]
you deaf people I guess that wasn't like
a big thing then I guess not but it's
just like what they didn't want to do it
or because I because I always put you
know I'm not completely deaf but I like
to put them on anyway just so I know how
to spell people's names and [__] but
they they don't have them I don't get it
so the first thing that happens
this happens in Bloomington Illinois uh
by the way and it happens in I think
like winter of 2003 they say so the
first thing that happens is that you
know Randy and Marcy are sleeping in
their house
and they get woken up by police sirens
like outside like they see the you know
the red and blue lights or whatever
and so Randy goes outside to see what
the hell is going on and it turns out I
mean he's a cop he's a detective so he
knows like you know all the cops that
are out there like on his lawn and he's
like yeah there was this guy on a
motorcycle and he lost control of the
motorcycle and he hit the tree which I
guess was like right in their front yard
right yeah like right there front yard
yeah so they're taking the guy away in
an ambulance he said well you know he's
conscious or something like that but you
know we don't we don't know so we're
taking him away in the reason I thought
there was a car too no no that was like
it was just a motorcycle yeah he just
like lost control and hit a tree okay
they showed a car that must have been
Witnesses stopping to see that yeah
there was like cops and [__] like that
like all and everybody like Robert back
and why not
um he said it was weird because they
didn't hear the actual accident which
you think they would because the tree
was like right there outside their
bedroom window apparently but they said
they got woke up by the lights okay
so so they took the guy away in an
ambulance
so
as I mentioned both of these both this
couple live worked in uh law enforcement
Marcy was actually the manager of the
the police dispatch
and Randy is a detective and has been
for several years so they both obviously
like work really really long hours
now a day or two later they find out
that the guy the biker guy that hit the
tree actually died like from his
injuries and Randy said we were really
surprised about that because we got the
impression when he was talking to the
cops that the that his injuries weren't
that bad but I guess they were worse
than they thought because the guy did
actually die and um you know so they
were a little weirded out that the dude
had died on their front lawn which yeah
that would be like a little bit freaky
now this isn't a case where they moved
into this house they've lived in this
house at this point in 2003 for eight
years and they said they kind of liked
it it's sort of like out in the not out
in the middle of nowhere but it was kind
of out in the middle of the country and
like you know kind of quiet and
everything
so the only other things about them they
have a son named Clint who is in the
military and he was deployed in the
Middle East
um and also they mentioned and this
actually does kind of play into the
story a little bit later on is that
Marcy's big dream is that she has always
wanted to ride a horse in a western like
in a movie and I was like that's weird
okay like I said that's again a very
specific significant dream but okay you
know you do you
so uh so yeah
um one night not too long after the
motorcycle wreck that killed the guy
they're laying on a couch watching a
movie a western as it happens
and the lights start flickering a lot of
flickering lights in this episode
now obviously at first they don't think
anything about it they just think oh you
know the electrical's [__] or whatever
we'll figure it out later
So Randy actually mostly works the
graveyard shift so he's usually away at
night as a lot of the men are in these
episodes I notice
so one night when Marcy is home by
herself
she hears like kind of a thumping noise
I guess it sort of sounds like somebody
is in the house like in the kitchen or
something
and so she gets up to go see what the
deal is and the lights in the hall like
start flickering again now in the
kitchen Marcy checks the back door which
is locked and it doesn't look like
anybody came in and she doesn't she
looks outside and doesn't see anybody
so she's like well
she figured it was just her imagination
but she's like a pretty goddamn show
like I heard somebody in the house and
she's not one and her husband said this
about her too it's like she's really not
one to you know be given to Flights of
Fancy or anything just like she's very
level-headed she's very down to earth
and she's not one of these people that
just like you know gets hysterical or
like makes stuff up so she's kind of
like I'm pretty sure I heard somebody in
the house but obviously there's nobody
here so I must have like imagined it
and then later on
um one day she's down in the basement
and she said that when she was down
there in particular she started to feel
like she was being watched all the time
like somebody was just standing right by
her or was like standing over there
looking at her or something like that
and it was starting to wig her out
so this one particular day the light
that was flickering all the time she
replaces the bulb that was in the
hallway and then
um she kind of goes just like oh that
job is done or whatever and then like
she walks back down the hall and then
the light comes on by itself I will note
that she did not say that she saw that
so I don't know if they just did that
for the show you know what I mean
because she didn't turn around and go
what the [__] you know it was just kind
of like they just made it come on by
itself
so apparently Marcy is really stressed
out
um you know because of work you know
she's been working long hours like I
said she works in police dispatch which
is probably like a pretty stressful job
too and also because as I mentioned
their son Clint has been deployed to the
Middle East and they haven't actually
heard from him for a couple of weeks so
they're worried that you know they don't
they don't know where he's at you know
they have because he hasn't called them
So Randy decides he's going to try and
cheer her up he's like his uh he sees in
the newspaper it's like hey there they
happen to be filming a western like
around here and they need extras so why
don't we go down there we'll be extras
because that's what you've always wanted
to do so you know he's trying to like
cheer up which that was kind of nice
so then
at another point in time Marcy is in the
kitchen
and she turns and sees that the back
door is open and she's pretty sure that
she did not leave it open so you know
she didn't see it open by itself or
anything like that and then the lights
start flickering again like over the
table
and then she turns around and sees a guy
standing in the doorway like she went
over and closed the back door and then
she kind of like turned around and was
walking over the dining room table and
then like the light over the dining room
table is flashing and then she turned
around and there was a dude like
standing and she [__] the actress in
this she was a great screamer I I
thought I mean she just she screamed for
Randy like that was the husband's name
and man she just she let it rip and I
was just like nice I like that
so
so she screams for him because he's home
uh and he runs out with his gun
obviously because like I said he's a cop
but the guys disappeared now she's like
there was a dude who was standing right
[__] there
so he checks like all around you know
the yard and everything like that but
obviously he can't find anybody and he
says to her he's like well what did he
look like she's like well I don't know
he's only there for a second he said he
was tall he's like he was looked like an
older guy she said remember he was
wearing jeans maybe like a white T-shirt
and Andy was like
he's like well I wanted to believe her
but I wasn't really sure like where the
dude could have gone to like in such a
short time
and he says and I know he's like but I
knew that she wasn't just like you know
nuts or whatever because it's like she's
a very rational person and she wasn't
really prone to imagining things he's
like but I didn't really know what to do
because I didn't see the guy and I
didn't see how he could have gotten away
so quickly felt the same way that that
night you woke me up said the doorbell
was ringing see they never they never
believe me no
I kind of thought I know I did believe
you remember when I checked it but I
didn't I didn't hear it
well here's and I I told you this before
because I was awake yeah and I heard it
and it was like 3 30 4 in the morning
yeah and I laid there and I was like
okay I'm wide awake and I'm pretty sure
I just heard the doorbell yeah I said
but I'm I'm willing to I'm like I know I
heard it but I was like I'm I'm willing
to think maybe it was a dream I know it
was a dream because I know it was wide
awake
but then I was laying there just like
debating this with myself and then it
rang again yeah that's when I woke you
up because I said okay I for sure did
not dream that because I'm laying here
Wide Awake you're upset
I had to go check that well see I didn't
think it was a ghost or nothing I
thought like some weirdo is ringing our
doorbell because it's never good if
somebody Rings your doorbell at [__]
four o'clock in the morning is it no
that's what I'm saying yeah I grabbed
the pistol went up there and [__]
started walking around in the dark and
trying to get looking because there was
a glass panes in our in the door at our
old house trying to look through to get
a certain angle to see if there's
anybody yeah we're like looking like
that like anybody there
I don't know who the [__] that was it
was spooky it was very spooky
but like I said if it hadn't rung again
I probably wouldn't have woken you up
because I would have just written it off
I know I heard it right but I would have
just written it off as like well maybe
it was a dream but then it did it rang
again and I was like okay that for sure
did not imagine that and that's when I
woke you up so it's running two times
you're wearing two times and that was
I'm sure it did well the garage door
opened yeah
on another
on another time yeah yeah it's pretty
weird yeah
yeah TV kept turning on yeah sometimes
in our room yeah that was around that
time
yeah it was pretty creepy then it pulled
down the [__] trim off the top of the
dam
kitchen cabinets yep so yeah that's what
it was that was I was apologize bringing
the [__] doorbell in the middle of
the night what an [__]
yeah I didn't pull the chain off the
door though
that's true yeah wow
you hit a chain one yeah Mark M said I
went to college in Bloomington oh well
so you know this town then that's where
that's where this uh story takes place
Bloomington
Illinois isn't there a Bloomington in
Indiana also or am I totally crazy
I mean I'm sure there's bloomingtons in
lots of States it's kind of one of those
it's like a town like Springfield where
every state has one
um but yeah
so later on like a couple months later
in Spring of 2003 Randy gets promoted to
Sergeant
so he's actually gone much longer hours
so now Marcy is home
alone like a lot more you know just when
she's starting to get like [__]
wigged out about maybe there's there's
some paranormal [__] going on so she
actually starts staying at work later to
avoid being home alone like for as long
as possible you know what I mean
now one of her co-workers I want to kind
of get into this in a little bit one of
her co-workers actually used to live in
her house like like didn't live with her
but lived there before they lived there
you know what I mean and she was like I
kind of wanted to ask her if any weird
[__] happened in the house like when she
lived there but she's like I wasn't
really sure she's like I didn't want her
to think I was nuts and I didn't
um you know it's just like there really
wasn't any right way to approach it like
hey by the way is that house haunted you
know what I mean she's like I didn't
really know how to because she I got the
impression that she felt really
silly like bringing it up to anybody
because she thought everybody would
think she was crazy she thought she was
crazy you know what I mean because like
I said she seemed like a really rational
person and she's like I just I I thought
I was losing my mind
but I guess a lot of people say that
so um their son Clint finally calls
and Marcy is like really really relieved
like he can only talk for a few minutes
and everything but she you know they
didn't they hadn't heard from her for
like two or three weeks and they were
like wondering where the [__] he was and
they were worried about him but he calls
and they're like okay so that's all good
now after she hangs up the phone with
her son
she said that she felt like she said it
felt like air like rushing at her like
from behind her like it kind of blew her
hair and like sort of pushed her like
that
and then she's like at this point she's
pretty well determined that yeah the the
[__] is haunted right so she just pretty
much yells at the ghost to like get the
[__] out of the house
um you know this is my house you don't
belong here blah blah
and then they show her later on in the
basement doing laundry because somebody
always has to do laundry in every single
episode of a haunting I've determined um
I'm gonna have to do a poll of that I
feel like every single episode of
Haunting has a scene of somebody doing
laundry at some point
and then when she's down in the basement
she starts seeing lights flickering like
from upstairs from the upstairs hallway
the light that flickered the most
because like the one that would um
sometimes flickered was like the sort of
chandelier thing that was like over the
kitchen table but the one that flickered
the most was the there was like a hall
light that was right by the door that
led to the basement I guess
so she was down in the basement and then
she looked up and saw the light in the
hallway like flickering outside it so
she kind of like goes up and the lights
flicking off and on and it's kind of
getting dark and everything and then
she's walking up the stair the stairs
and then apparently a hand reaches out
from like between the stairs and like
grabs her leg like grabs her ankle I
don't know if she saw the hand or if she
just felt it yeah or thought that it
would happen or thought that it happened
I'm not really sure I don't I didn't get
the impression that she actually saw the
hit they show it obviously like on the
show but she just said she felt like
something yeah like like she felt a hand
around her ankle yeah which when me and
Wes were uh walking around inside mouth
Mountain
in the in that Ski Resort
every time we walked up the stairs
together we would start running because
it felt like there was something behind
us chasing us but we'd look back there'd
be nothing there just yeah kids are but
yeah definitely a poltergeist [__] going
on in there
because you said you said you kept
thinking you turn around it'd be like a
skeleton yeah I kept I wanted to turn
around but I was afraid to but I would
anyway there's nothing there
but uh Wes would be running from it too
like there was something back there
yeah yeah
you feel some kind of pressure back
there some kind of presence
it's creepy chasing you up the stairs
but not no sounds just totally silent
you know I feel like someone's watching
you coming upstairs with you
it's weird
so maybe she's maybe they're just trying
to say maybe
she's going upstairs and she was always
had a constant fear that something was
going to grab her
yeah I mean like I said she did kind of
say that she felt did she feel like a
hand or grabbing her ankle but I don't
know if she actually saw a hit like a
physical hand reaching out but she said
she felt like that
so she's um understandably like pretty
[__] wigged out by this so she calls
Randy and she's like basically like
something [__] touched me okay and I
don't like it and um
he's he doesn't really know what to do
he's like well I can come home but he's
like a lot of the dudes on on a haunting
where he's just like you know like I
said you can't it's a ghost you can't
punch it so they're like well I'm out of
ideas you know what I mean he's like
even if I come home like there's nothing
I can do it's like you know it's a ghost
presumably so I can't do anything about
it and I don't really know like what she
wants me to do about it
so while while uh Marcy is waiting for
Randy to come home
she basically goes in there and tapes
the basement dorsia likes he keeps the
[__] ghost from busted out of there
which like I said I can't really say a
blamer to be honest with you
um so Randy comes home and he takes all
the tape off the basement door and goes
down in there and looks around
um and doesn't see anything they kind of
set it up like he's gonna see something
like because they it kind of went on a
long time and it was kind of creepy and
they kind of like shot from behind
various things like someone was watching
him but he didn't say he saw anything
he's like I just went down there and
like nothing happened
and then she tells him
she's like look every time I'm in this
house by myself she's like I feel like
someone is standing right in front of me
like all the time yeah I know that
feeling yeah and again like he didn't
really know what to do about it you know
yeah he was like come on woman
give me something to work with well
that's what I mean maybe but give me
something to work and I kind of feel
like well the thing about it too is that
it's it I think about this a lot like
when we're watching the thing because I
get it I get that the dudes are like
they feel helpless and they feel like
you know because it's like oh and you
know I can't protect my family or
whatever because it's a ghost you can't
punch it like I said yeah but a lot of
times
I think that they don't really yeah they
you know the the women and the kids like
yes they want the problem solved
obviously but they don't necessarily
want you to punch the ghost or anything
like that they just want somebody to
believe them and like their feelings to
be validated and you to like work with
them to like come to a solution they
don't need you to fix it you know what I
mean a lot of times they just want you
to make them feel better about it yeah
my friend Ed Dunham who was in one of
these the the Deltona ghost what was it
called haunting haunting in Florida I
think it was just called yeah yeah I
know him he's an Army Ranger he tried to
kill the damn ghost He says you can't do
anything with it you can't [__] punch
it you can't shoot it
just it's there no matter what he said
he saw the guy yeah saw the guy sitting
on the bed [__] smoking looking at
him until he was covered he was wet like
Covered in Rain like he'd been outside
when it's raining
same song Once little kids his kids felt
its presence and stuff
much stuff happened it's a good episode
also
I was considering like revisiting that
one yeah because I know we did a show
about it like a long time ago yeah maybe
I'll update that one but yeah because I
when I was looking at the episode list
but I kind of want to do the ones we
haven't done yet and then maybe I mean I
know we we redid Summer Wind and we've
redone some that we did before but that
but that was one that I kind of wanted
to redo because you because you know
that guy and yeah
um and that was actually like a pretty
decent and that's not far from here like
that house yeah and you've driven by it
before I stopped out there and looked
see if I could pick up any kind of vibe
from it like over a mammoth and I
couldn't
didn't feel anything
just felt normal
yeah I mean that house whatever is it's
gone I don't know that house is only
about 20 miles from where I grew up
actually and it's not the one they show
in the episode
but you said it was on the same street
it's on the same street yeah yeah the
show The Corner house because it's real
nice the one he was in was not on the
corner it's not quite that nice
yeah and again that's he was just
renting it it wasn't his house right
that's kind of something I'm always
interested in is like how far away they
it was about five houses down yeah one
that they showed
it was a nice neighborhood
yeah well it's an older neighborhood I
haven't been to Delta for a while yeah
um but no he he would
not a parapsychologist and some local
spiritualists got involved I really
didn't really agree with that too much
um I didn't think they were the right
people were on it but that's all he had
access to like a ghost hunting club
basically right
although the main woman did give him the
I think pretty good advice like you know
tone the emotions down you can't
physically fight this thing you might
just be feeding it you know feeding it a
bunch of energy
to uh
or encouraging it you know
to do more
that it could be
well I mean that's kind of what a lot of
parapsychologists and you know ghost
hunting type people will say is that
probably sometimes like the best thing
you can do is just pretend it's not
there yeah because if you're scared of
it or if you're angry or something like
that then it loves that [__] he said he
could hear it at night walking across
the rafters up in the ceiling with heavy
boots
going from one
um we're after to the next and then he
said he'd hear it on the roof walking
around on a roof he ran out and yelled
at It Up on the Roof I think he said he
saw it it just was just a black form
yeah they showed that in the episode
that he saw like a figure up on the road
yeah
that's funny because like I said my my
grandfather's old house which is not
there anymore it was in South Daytona
um my uh my mom and all my sisters said
that they heard somebody boots walking
around on the roof all the time yeah
when they were kids Ed said he had bad
dreams in there and
all kinds you know bad dreams too
I think when they moved in there I think
there's a bunch of eaten food just
sitting on plates just left in the like
somebody ran away from eating like
that's right yeah they showed down the
episode too that was like really weird
he said it was strange a lot of
furniture was left behind and food was
left behind like somebody just ran
yeah see that's where I wouldn't be as
weirded out by Furniture but yeah if
somebody just like ran a like a half
eaten plate of food that that's pretty
weird sitting there
I've been there for a long time
you know and the place wasn't in squalor
right
like somebody just like left and then
come back and then weird that like
nobody especially if they were gonna
rent it out like that nobody like the
you know the management company didn't
come and like clean it up right I
remember correctly it's very weird Ed
did that for a living and that was part
of the deal is going there and cleaning
it up and he I think he'd get a discount
on the uh oh I got you I want to think
if I remember correctly so he was also
cleaning up and getting it ready for
himself and then they would subtract
that from you know
because they wouldn't have to hire us
they wouldn't have to hire somebody
because he was a contractor right I got
you
so uh so yeah so she basically tells us
how he found the place okay I remember
that makes sense so he got a deal on it
yeah because it was kind of left a
little bit Yeah they need to hired him
to clean the place up and then he
realized he he wanted to rent it
and they subtracted that from the from
from his bill I think they did mention
that on the episode actually maybe we
should revisit that one because I
actually do really like that episode and
like I said you you know that guy
so um so yeah so she tells Randy that
yeah basically every time she's in the
house she's like I feel like someone's
standing like right
right in my face like pretty much like
all the time and it's freaking me out
so Marcy not really knowing what else to
do she finally decides she's going to
ask the co-worker because remember the
co-worker that lived in her house like a
long time ago she's going to ask the
co-worker about the house and the
co-worker is super helpful
um and that's sarcasm if you didn't
detect that basically she just looks at
her and she's like because Marcy's like
you ever have anything weird happen at
that house you know and she's like weird
like what what do you mean weird she's
like I don't know just you know lights
going on and off by themselves or like
weird noises or something like that and
the woman legit like like I don't know
if she did this in real life but she
legit like looks at Marcy is like are
you nuts like that and I was like that's
nice like
way to be supportive there co-worker
yeah she was like super [__] so uh
Marcy was like well uh okay that was
just never mind uh just forget I said
anything you know so I was just like I
don't know why that scene made me laugh
so much just like the way the woman was
like are you nuts
you know she didn't she wasn't even
interested like you know she's like oh
is the house haunted wow no nothing
happened when I was there it's like I
wouldn't be an [__] like that but you
know
so uh one night not too long after this
uh both of them are sleeping and they
get woke up or at least Marcy gets woke
up by a blue kind of light thing
it looked like a blue glow
missed it she said it was a blue mist
right yeah that's what she called it
which like yeah that reminded me of like
your thing because that's what you
called it too like a blue mist they
didn't show it the way it actually
looked for us but maybe that's the way
it looked for them yeah the the way they
showed it it kind of looked like in
Poltergeist you know what I mean like
wasn't there that scene in Poltergeist
where that thing like started
materializing like at the end of their
bed it kind of looked like that like a
blue glowy thing yeah it made it look
like a head Misty places of density in
it right right ours wouldn't like that
it was just a
solid field like a field of energy or
like when you look across the a foggy
you know like like a foggy field or
something it just looks like a
solid block of haze so it was like that
but you really couldn't put your hand on
it or anything and it didn't look like
smoke it's the same color as smoke
particles
like you know smoke when cigarette smoke
gets really dissipated yeah it's like
that but
you could tell the particles weren't
moving it
we weren't sure if it was just like some
kind of energy field or if you were just
or something that was affecting your eye
to make you see it it was weird
me and red sit there trying to analyze
that [__] for [__] hours
you know
how is it doing that what are we
actually seeing that kind of stuff
is it there or are we just seeing it is
it making us see it that kind of is it
really there we don't know
put your hand through it you don't
really disturb it walk in and it goes
away advantages that like almost like a
mirage
it's real fate
well you can see it
you know
blue haze kind of thing speaking of haze
I was like [__] man driving to work this
morning and I was like it was [__]
thick as pea soup out there yeah I could
barely [__] see I was like driving
down I'm driving down the street it's
like 6 30 in the morning and I'm like
driving another [__] I was like oh my
God it's like Hound of the [__]
[__] Baskervilles out here I couldn't
see anything it was horrible
at least there's not much traffic like
until I get out of all of that but yeah
so she said that she woke up and she saw
like a blue mist at the end of the bed
and she said it was right in front of
her face
and she kind of like freezes up like she
sort of like reaches for it but then it
disappears and then she wakes Randy up I
don't know why she didn't wake him up
when it was still there but I guess she
was like who freaked out or whatever but
by the time she wakes him up it's gone
so now she's basically like okay well
now I don't feel safe anywhere because
this is like the first time she'd seen
any kind of like manifestation in the
bedroom and it was the first time she'd
seen like a kind of manifestation when
Randy was right there like he was
sleeping but I mean it happened when he
was in the house before because she did
see that Apparition and Randy was in the
house he just was in the other room you
know what I mean but she said so now
it's kind of the thing where it's like I
don't feel safe anywhere like I don't
feel safe in the house anywhere and I
don't feel safe now when Randy is home
because obviously it's gonna do [__]
like when he's right there
um so she's like well maybe we just need
to call somebody and she basically said
she said something funny and I wrote it
down she said I wasn't looking for a
support group I just wanted to know that
this happened to someone else like
because she wanted some validation I
guess because she thought she was losing
it you know
so she's still kind of reluctant to call
investigators though because I think she
was still like I said I think she was
really worried that people would think
she was crazy or that you know they
would laugh at her or something like
that
um she's like I didn't really want to
like have people come to my house or
whatever
now one night she actually wakes up and
sees the guy that she saw by the back
door earlier like the the ghost guy like
in the white T-shirt or whatever and she
sees him in the hall outside the bedroom
with two women like he looks like he's
pushing the women like down into the
basement and she said that he actually
turned and looked right at her like
before he pushed the two women into the
basement
so at this point she like wakes Randy up
Randy gets the gun and goes down to the
basement again
and you know the lights flicker and
stuff like that and the ghost kind of
pops up behind him but he didn't say he
saw that so they kind of set it up like
oh he's gonna see something but he
didn't you know what I mean he was down
there a long time but they kept going
like she putting the ghost in the
background but he doesn't see it
um so yeah again like he's trying to be
supportive but he's like look I really
don't see anything he doesn't feel
anything and you know he's he doesn't
think she's going crazy but he just
doesn't know what to do you know Mark
says it seems to be a consistent report
that you have a feeling of presence in a
haunted house yeah I actually don't
really
consider it a feeling of presence I felt
it it feels more like something's
watching you and it's scrutinizing you
not so much just a presence
like someone's looking directly at you
yeah so not just that somebody's hanging
out but somebody's actually like acts
like they're looking at you
and there's emotion behind it that it it
hates you or
or it doesn't like you or you know you
there is like an emotion kind of
associated with it looking at you
although the emotion does kind of change
it's not always like that it might
even be playful sometimes just
yeah I think I would rather have a nice
ghost that would be nice it seemed to
just mirror whatever your
emotion was
if you got scared it would just become
more frightening
if you got lighthearted about it it
would start to play
but that's Poltergeist that's not
ghost Poltergeist is rspk recurrent
spontaneous psychokinesis of the
subconscious mind to do it artificial
ghost
I believe there may be our ghosts I've
never seen one but I've been in a bad
house which that might be a ghost
but nothing ever moved couldn't prove it
just a feeling of being watched bad
dreams
not just me everybody
went in the house very uncomfortable
but nothing ever happened
yeah
so okay so where was I okay so um
basically he's like again he still
hasn't seen anything and he doesn't
really know what to do he's like well
why don't you go we'll go and work on
that movie like we'll go be extras in
the movie just to get out of the house
like as much as possible because she
doesn't really like to be in there by
herself anymore
now one night it so happens that Marcy
is at work and Brandy is at home for a
change
and he actually experiences something
finally now in the reenactment they
actually showed he's in the fridge
[__] around and you know because they
do this in like horror movies it's
almost as ubiquitous as that mirror
thing like oh I'm gonna wash my face oh
[__] something in the mirror yeah this
is kind of like oh I'm getting something
out of the refrigerator and then you
close the refrigerator door and then
there's a ghost like right there so
that's what they did
so he's getting a beer or whatever out
of the fridge and then he closes the
fridge door and then the ghost is there
and it's like screaming like like right
at his face now he didn't say he saw it
though but he said he heard it yeah he
said it was really loud and it was right
on top of me like I guess a dude
screaming and it was like on one side
and then it was like on the other side
that would [__] make my hair stand up
yeah I would [__] my pants if that
happened legitimately I'm like not even
ashamed to say that like if you if
you're just like [__] around getting
some out of the refrigerator and all of
a sudden like there's some dude right
there like screaming in your ear oh my
God that would be [__] horrifying I
well [__] I jump it sounds when I know
what it is you know what I mean like
much less it being something from the
[__]
other side of the veil or whatever but
yeah so they they showed it like on the
show they showed the dude like right
there like oh like screaming like that
but he didn't see it I don't think he
just like heard it but he said it was
really really loud
so he's like and finally I realizes uh
you know he realized that oh this is
what Marcy is talking about holy [__]
this is [__] terrifying so he's like
no wonder she's so [__] up like is if
this is what she's been going through
for the last few months or whatever
so um so then now that they're like he
tells her he's like oh my God now I know
what you're talking about this is awful
and then they so now they're kind of
like on the same page
so then they start wondering well
does maybe this has something to do with
that guy that died on our front lawn
like maybe he's the one haunting it
because like I said they lived in this
house for like eight years before any of
this [__] started happening and no
presumably they hadn't had any trouble
prior to that so they said well maybe
you know maybe it's the guy that was on
the motorcycle that died or you know
maybe something so they're like maybe it
had something to do with that
so
um they actually discuss moving but
um they say they weren't really ready to
they had been talking about moving
um kind of out to out to a farm or
something like that like when they
retired but they weren't like retirement
age yet and he's like I don't really
want to retire yet and it's like so
we're you know we don't really want to
be chased out of our house or whatever
so
um what they try to do is just try to
spend as much time as possible like out
of the house like I said they're you
know being extras they but they both end
up being extras in the in the movie or
whatever
now it so happens that while they're on
the set you know with their little
cowboy hats and whatnot
the director's brother who is also like
helping out on the movie
happens to be a Paranormal Investigator
who'da thought it I was like wow what a
coincidence that is
and his name is Rob Conover I think is
what they said I'm not sure if I spelled
it right in my notes but yeah I'm pretty
sure that's what they said
so he seems like reluctant to tell me
he's like I'm uh I'm a Paranormal
Investigator you know everybody's that
kind of thing
but uh Marcy's like well uh our [__]
house is haunted so you want to hear
about that and like so she tells him all
about The Apparition
and Rob just from what she says seems
very concerned about it because they're
like well this Apparition seems that
like it's trying to
deliberately scare you and he's like and
that's usually bad news
so um he's like basically what you need
to do is control your fear because the
ghost feed off the fear of them it's
like it seems like that's what this one
is doing so you know you just have to
like try to not show any fear around it
like you know easier said than done I
guess
so Mercy is stuck Home Alone one night
and she starts like sensing the ghost's
presence now Rob had told her to you
know if you get really scared in the
house get your Bible or whatever and
start reading the 23rd psalm
so she starts doing that
and then the kitchen sink the faucet
like turns on by itself
and Marcy is like [__] this [__] pretty
much uh and calls Rob and it's like you
know get over here out of you know I'm
done dealing with this okay
so um so he comes there even though it's
like the middle of a storm or something
like that because I think she said
something about oh thanks for coming out
even though the weather's so shitty or
whatever
so he starts walking around the house
and you know you can tell he has a very
very concerned look on his face like oh
she is some bad mojo in here so he said
he felt a strong Spirit energy and he
said he's hiding for me that's what he
said I remember
so there's more lights flickering and
then
all the power goes out now I will note
that there was a bad storm outside so
that might not have been some ghosty
[__] that might have just been like
power going out because it was a storm
or whatever
and then there's kind of like they're
looking down the hall and then like that
blue light mist kind of situation like
sort of starts coalescing down there
like at the end of the hall
so Robin Marcy kind of like light the
lamp or candles or whatever and they
kind of start going on the holler
looking down there now Rob sees the
ghost He says and asks who he is now
Marcy says that she saw the blue light
and she sees like the guy's outline she
didn't see him like real clearly because
like I said she saw The Apparition
before at least she said she did
so Rob said he sees a couple of women
goes too because remember I said that
Marcy saw the the guy and like two women
like and he was pushing them down the
basement
and he said that he saw the the two
women ghosts and they looked all [__]
up like they're all bloody and why not
and he said because he was like oh I
usually see them like the way they
looked them when they died I was like
okay that's horrifying
now they figure out that the man ghost
is controlling the female ghost because
you can't just have a ghost in a house
you always have to have one ghost that's
like corralling like all the other
ghosts and being like an [__] about
it so that's what you have in this
situation too
now Rob actually senses something
because
um remember there was like the
motorcycle accident but Rob senses
something that happened actually 60
years ago he says if it was about 60
years ago
he said
um and Tom was talking about this
earlier but the ghost man was apparent
well if he wasn't a ghost then obviously
when he was alive uh the ghost man was
apparently molesting his daughter
and when the mom found out about it
they're all in the car together and
she's like is it Trio and he's like you
know what I mean kind of like that and
she was like all right [__] for
sure and she just like what are you
gonna do about it right and she's like
I'll shake what I'm gonna do about it
mothers I'm gonna kill all of us you
know what I mean I was like I said she
ain't playing so um so she just like
crashed the [__] car and killed them
all uh and apparently this car crash
happened on the land where the house
stands like before the house you know
was there obviously
so um because he says something to
Marcy's like well there's something
about a crat a car crash and she's like
no it was a motorcycle crash you know it
just happened a few months ago and he's
like no no this happened like a really
really long time ago so they didn't
really explicitly say that maybe the guy
dying in the motorcycle crash like
recently
maybe
awakened the other [__] The Awakening
yeah I think that's why they called it
that because like I said they lived in
this house for a long time and they'd
never had like any ghosts before so
maybe this just kind of like stirred it
up I don't really know I think that's
kind of what they were applying
so Rob's like
I just I don't know I kind of I laughed
at the way he phrased this I guess but
he's like Rob's gonna talk to the ghost
I'm gonna I'm gonna talk to these
[__] I'm gonna talk to the
ghost hold my beer yeah
we'll talk I'm gonna go over here and
talk to these guys for a second but well
yeah that's that's why I laughed because
that's kind of like what his tone
sounded like let me go back but let me
talk to you
no you can't stay
[Laughter]
yeah
I mean so yeah so he's gonna talk to
them about going into the light because
you know that's that's what you got to
do man you can't like hang out
now uh he says that the man ghost
um apparently didn't want to go into the
lake well because he was afraid he was
going to go to hell or he was going to
get punished for being a [__] now when
he was alive you know what I mean yeah
which you know that little daughter well
yeah I mean probably that's a legitimate
fear I guess but hey should have thought
of that before he did it that's that's
all I got to say that's what that's what
I mean
so you know diddlers to yourself
yeah seriously that's your daughter man
come on even if it wasn't your daughter
just like you keep your [__] filthy
ass yourself well I know it makes it a
lot worse but I'm just saying it's like
just keep your filthy ass pause to
yourself I don't care who it is but uh
yeah so he's afraid to go now so we
actually see kind of like a flashback of
I don't know if like Rob to really saw
this or not but it's like we see like a
flashback of the wife and daughter
like they're all bloody and [__] up
and everything and they're kind of
waking up in the [__] up car
and they're like oh we're dead I guess
and they're like we got away from our
horrible husband slash dad
and they start getting out of the car
because there's like woo this whirly
light you know what I mean so they're
gonna go into delay and then the dad
like tries to grab the mom like as she's
getting out of the car like no you're
not going anywhere [__] like
that kind of thing and I'm just like
geez even in death he's like [__]
won't even let her go to the light just
pissed off
so uh yeah but basically she just gets
out and she's just like bye you know
what it means like that kind of thing so
they just like leave this scumbag hubby
in the car
um say just but then they just leave his
ass there so they just go into the light
so the man Spirit who's now back in the
house because Rob is still talking to
this he's talking to the ghosts uh the
man Spirit then realizes now he's alone
because the wife and the daughter
finally were like you know [__] off and
they just like went off into the light
because I guess they were scared to you
before he was keeping them there somehow
um so he was apparently asking Rob the
psychic guy if he was going to Hal and
if it's gonna hurt and all this other
kind of stuff yeah dude said some crazy
[__] and Rob's like
I don't know I guess you'll find out
I don't remember exactly what he said he
said some crazy [__] that I tried to
analyze he goes I don't know and he goes
and then he goes he goes I don't know if
you'll be bonus and he goes that he says
what is this
the devil's punishment is much worse
than God's judgment
oh yeah is that what he said yeah I
should have written that down because we
were discussing that yeah the devil's
punishment is much worse than God's
judgment and I'm like wait a minute
God's judgment against you would be that
you'd be punished by the devil it'd be
the same thing
yeah they didn't really think that
through
[Laughter]
I'd been like yeah you're going to hell
[__] like I said I should have
thought of that before you did all that
[__] up [__] while you're relaxed is
that you're already being punished by
the devil which I didn't really see that
because he said he was in a self-made
Purgatory so he's not being punished by
the Devil he's in purgatory
so but what he what he meant to say is
something like you're already being
punished by the devil what do you have
to lose by getting judgment because you
might you know get a lesser sentence is
what is what I believe he meant that's
not what he said
doctor
[Laughter]
[Music]
it doesn't really but like I said they
weren't really thinking about it they're
just pulling stuff out their ass it's
just it's ghost stuff they don't know
yeah they've already according to new
testament old testament
stuff I don't think there's a purgatory
the closest thing to that would be maybe
something from the Old Testament called
Shield or just means the grave
but death you know there was no real
afterlife guaranteed in the Old
Testament you just died
only certain people went to heaven guys
like Moses and [__] because the heaven
was special [__] Heaven Was
Made For Angels it wasn't made for human
souls and if you look in the New
Testament with with Revelations
at end times prophecy
the dead when Jesus comes back the dead
rise from Shoal they rise from the grave
and come back to life eventually they're
given new bodies and they live in a New
Jerusalem on Earth which is kind of like
uh the second Eden restoration of Eden
there isn't anything really about going
to heaven
not in not in the prophecy end time
prophecy so
although other Christians I think
mention it
some people being translated to heaven
I don't really think heaven is
was the main concept in Christianity
Christianity came from many competing
versions of Christianity none of them
really agreed they ended up being
harmonized and put into the New
Testament
by whatever faction one
over time
but I'd be interested to say maybe
somebody could pull that up I don't
think it's I don't think reward
Eternal reward is heaven
maybe that's something from the Pauline
material
but Pauline material says all kinds of
[__] a lot of the Pauline material is
fake okay that's all I'm gonna say about
it
I was gonna say uh
uh I forgot oh well I'm sure it's just
funny a lot of this is tradition yeah
it's a lot of this is tradition it's not
really scriptural
but uh but yeah so they get the man
ghost the The [__] diddling man
ghost uh to [__] off and go to his
wherever he went to to get punished
forever or whatever
and as soon as he [__] off uh all the
power comes back on
and they said they noticed that I'm
presuming they mean the basement door
because I guess that's where you know
the whole basement thing was going on
that's where the energy was coming from
or whatever they said once the guy once
the man goes kind of like this man goes
well once he kind of like disappeared
they said one side of the door was like
really really hot and then the other
side was like cold like normal you know
what I mean that's what Marcy said
anyway
so then afterward they jump ahead and uh
you know their son Clint comes home for
um presuming on leave and they introduce
him to rob the psychic who got the
ghosts out their house and apparently
everything's okay now uh the wyckoffs
actually stayed in the house uh I don't
know if they're still in there now or if
they're even still alive because this
was a while back they weren't that old
um to be honest
uh yeah but they stayed there and had no
more activity and at the very end of the
show it said they are still
investigating the deaths on their
property which to me uh means they
didn't find anything about that hole
because that seems
like something that because when did he
say okay so yeah it would have been the
50s because it happened and this
happened it took place in 2003 and he
said it was 60 years ago yeah that it
happened so they had newspapers then
like you wouldn't you know they
something like that would have been big
news it would have been I would imagine
there would have been local records of
that probably right
so the fact that they just kind of said
that oh they're still trying to find I'm
like well if there was information to
find you would have found it like
immediately they would have been in
microfiche probably by that time
definitely yeah remember microfiche
over there
from another era I know I wonder if like
any younger people what the [__] is that
microfiches you they take they take
photographs of old
um newspapers and take a photograph of
the whole thing a whole page and shrink
it down to damn near microscopic level
and put it on a slide
and then they would take that and file
that in a library
so you could look up any day in any date
of newspapers local in your area at the
library and it just come on a little
slide you put that in the microfiche
field and then you can like move it
around yeah so that way you could have
like a whole month
of newspapers
on a single
micro yeah like on a little bitty like
on a little bitty slide
and they're even like guides to it
because they were coordinates down and
over there was numbers to show you what
to land on a page you were looking for
if it was an important page
where certain things were you know what
I mean like events but basic [__] you
had to read through it it would take
forever there was no Google search
yeah it's crazy well sometimes you see
that like in older movies like I'm
looking through like the microface and
stuff I remember like because our
library where I grew up I used to go to
the Ormond library and they had like
you'd come in in the front like right by
the circulation desk and then like right
by that they had like all these little
doors because they're like little
closets sort of and it was just like a
little this little dark cubby
that you could close in there that had
like a long thing and had all the
microfiche machines so you could go in
there in the dark and like scroll
through the [__] yeah you know what I
mean microfiche porn
in case you know that's probably yeah
you know but anyway
it was funny the uh
you they probably in certain rich areas
or wealthier areas have probably put all
that microfiche stuff they probably
digitized it all I would imagine which
that'd make it so much easier
because they want a search engine it
they've been as because I do a lot of um
research for my True Crime stuff and
everything
and they have been slowly digitizing
like old newspapers but it's kind of Hit
or Miss yeah I should be able to see it
well I mean they're doing a good job
though because I can find like some
really old ass newspapers and it's like
you can go in there and it has like the
whole page and everything and and it
even
um it'll even do uh like the what um
it'll a little I can't even think of
like the word that I'm trying to think
of
see if you like it can tell what it says
whatever it reads it and it reads it
knows what it says yeah and then it can
put that into into a digital format that
you can search through like a Google
search that'd be great when it comes to
things like land deed records and [__]
like that and all the Civil records of
how property has changed hands you can
probably do a lot of cool investigation
with that yeah find out who who owned
what piece of property what time and how
many pieces of property they owned stuff
like that yeah I mean I'm sure like a
lot of paper records have been lost in
various fires and floods and [__] like
that but they do seem to be trying to
like digitize everything really cool you
take them hand written letters that have
survived for over hundreds of years and
let AI read all that and organize
everybody's all the surviving personal
leather letters
that way you could look through those
for any references for certain things
that you may be looking for names and
[__]
that would be really cool yeah
well doesn't like um be able to check
history and stuff like well who's that
like um that uh Genealogy website like
uh ancestry.com or whatever I feel like
they do a lot of that kind of stuff yeah
like they have like old correspondence
and stuff like that they have a lot of
that stuff digitized you can look up
because they're always putting new stuff
up you could say I wanna all
correspondence that was written you know
on this date somewhere you know in the
United States during the Civil War I
just want to see what those people were
talking about was there any references
to this battle or is there any reference
to this person and [__] people may have
discussed what it is you're looking for
in those letters yes they wrote letters
to each other and discussed [__] in them
yeah because it's not like you could
just pick up the phone and call somebody
back then yeah that would help fill in a
lot of gaps of certain things that
happened in the South yeah as it was
[__] falling apart
Mark says I feel like a lot of 80s and
early 90s mystery movies had the scene
where the main character figures some
important [__] out with my professional
Library yeah there are a lot of scenes
like that like microfiche was creepy man
it is it's still kind of creepy it makes
a good movie scene
yeah it's it's actually like a lot
creepier than just watching somebody do
like a Google search or whatever which
is you know not inherently creepy right
and I guess like the the farther away we
get from microfiche technology like the
creepier will seem because it's just
like this really old like endocrinistic
yo we have to go back to microfiche oh
yeah yeah
hold on let me put my cloak on yeah
okay we're gonna go check out laughs
thank you David June love y'alls thank
you we need to do we need to print his
shirts actually oh yeah maybe you should
do that tomorrow somebody was asking yes
right I didn't ever got the order you
got the order yeah yeah okay yeah I told
you about it she didn't tell me about it
yeah it did you did yeah it did okay
I'll I'll print them yeah so I had I
have the shirt set aside I just got I
just gotta yeah we just got to print
them real quick and I got all the stuff
to mail them so we can just do it in the
next couple days uh Ben says that
microfiche is very flammable yeah that's
why I kind of feel like they're just
trying to digitize everything too
because that stuff is it won't one it
won't last forever and two yeah it might
catch fire so you know all right um is
that all that we have to say about this
particular episode it was a good episode
um yeah I actually forgot how good this
one was it makes a good Standalone watch
kind of like you know
I'll probably put it above Amityville
Horror in a way a lot a lot of these
episodes are actually better than the
amp the original Amityville movie
when you go back and watch the
Amityville movie it's kind of thin by
today's standards these are actually
kind of better
they're good watches and did this happen
I don't know
yeah I don't know maybe this seemed more
like a straight up ghost story than a
lot of the other ones but in a way
that's kind of like refreshing because I
like that there was no demons involved
there was no
it wasn't like as hokey as some of the
other ones I guess like I hate that I
hate that a lot of them just went like
in a whole demonic Direction the people
in general seem credible yeah and they
didn't seem yeah yeah I mean they seemed
pretty level-headed and pretty you know
it wasn't Flights of Fancy in it or
anything right they weren't being
attacked by APAP and ancient Egyptian
gods and scarab beetles weren't eating
them and you know
that episode was those dude those boys
were trolling they were [__] troll
they trolled the [__] out of [__] a
haunted
I think they did well they're probably
like the producers of a haunting were
like whatever we don't care we just need
content we need content people will
watch it regardless they don't give a
[__] if they're how believable it is
well because like I said it started
going crazy it's like you know it's like
now it's witches and now the house is
surrounded by werewolves and like all
those other kinds oh the werewolf would
the house surrounded by werewolves was
actually I think that was Paranormal
Witness which a Paranormal Witness
started off really good but then that
one went South that one went Pokey yeah
and actually for a time we kind of liked
Paranormal Witness better because they
actually they had a tendency to actually
show like the actual evidence
photographs and actually they'd play you
actual EVPs like from the thing where
like a haunting will never does that no
but in Paranormal Witness did that but
then Paranormal Witness started getting
silly too like as it went on like you
have to buy werewolves yeah you remember
that Werewolf episode holy [__] I was
like you were to stop you were not
attacked but attacked by where I was
like yeah and it wasn't just one
werewolf either it was like a whole
bunch of them like surrounding the house
I was like dude that was a bear yeah
calm down werewolves are sexy man
there's a whole [__]
genre of werewolf porn yes I I said it's
very popular yeah yeah like a World of
Warcraft characters these sexy girls
like a sumi and [__] how does God
sneaking out at night having sex with
the werewolves out in the [__] forest
and [__]
well [__] that was one of the whole you
know you know you know you know Twilight
yeah
um you know that was like her and the
vampire but yeah she also had a there
was no werewolves in that one too yeah
yeah Jacob was a werewolf yeah so it was
like vampires versus where and she was
kind of like you had the hots for the
women yeah and they're like [__]
seven feet tall and they're jacked as
[__] they're like they're like the
werewolves from wolfen
big old red rockets and [__]
we never did we never did do wolfen did
we no we need to do that one we need to
do that we need to review that movie
I was actually thinking of howling I
said yeah but they look like the digs
out of the howling we now we have done
the howling yeah but I I remember I
wrote it down a long time ago but I used
to love wolf and man and I haven't seen
it in like such a long time I used to
see it on cable like when I was a kid
all the time yeah but uh that's a that's
a definitely a movie that we should
cover because I remember liking that
quite a bit
all right so uh so yeah the awakening
season four pretty decent episode all
around especially if you like more ghost
story ones and not like demonic kind of
stuff and and nothing that's like too
silly this one didn't get like too silly
which I kind of appreciated
uh but yeah so I guess we'll wrap it up
for the evening so I can
kind of get ready for
to crash down for the night yeah so
Wednesday night our show is gonna be I'm
actually kind of looking forward to this
one
this was a recommendation by one of
y'all I can't remember who for like a
from quite a while back and then I put
it in the poll and it finally won we are
going to be talking about Billy Milligan
who is uh they called him the campus
rapist back in the 1970s but the
fascinating thing about him was there's
um multiple personality disorder kind of
thing involved and he is actually the
guy on whom the character from M Night
shyamalan's split is Loosely based uh
you know so he was the one of the first
well he was I think as far as I know
like the only guy to use
successfully
um the my other personality did the
crimes and I didn't remember it you know
what I mean yeah so um there's actually
a four-part
Netflix documentary about him
I think it's called Monsters Inside and
I'm actually watching that like so I
watched the first two episodes last
night and so I might watch one tonight
and then I'll watch another one tomorrow
night because it's like it's it's
actually like a really interesting story
yeah Billy Milligan based on true story
um
David June good show peeps take it easy
thank you and said still impressed at
how jacked Tom got oh yeah
man
The Showdown man I've been acting ass
for a couple months I was on trend
I was on trend for like five months
yeah it only took like a two week break
in between two cycles
because I was on train I thought I
thought I could do that
I've been off for about three weeks I
still like to ask sometimes yeah you do
so you got y'all and then you have to
forgive me if I could and then I tell
him he's acting an ass and then he and
then he acts like an even bigger ass
because he doesn't believe me yeah I
don't believe it because but then like
later on he's like oh yeah I was like I
know yeah
I seem normal and then like so I go
crying the [__] self man she doing
this and that she goes no you're crazy
and I said no I'm not no I'm not thank
you Sophie yeah
[Laughter]
you kind of descended into madness
sometimes see I told you and I was like
no no no no no and then I started doing
the numbers and going like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
on Trend yeah don't you [__] be crazy
me dudes be crazy yeah sorry dude yeah
you kind of have like these emotional
[__] Holograms or not Holograms
emotional hallucinations emotional
Holograms yeah
but I'm off that [__] now
I'm on MPP now that's a good one I'm
gonna get better you down with MPP I'm
an MPP yeah yeah you know me yeah and
alone as it was a lot more mild got a
hole in my lip doesn't have the same
mental side effects I'm gonna we'll tell
you all we got bodybuilders that listen
like Ian you know he's he's waiting to
do his transcycle do it man but it's a
it's a relationship killer you better
have and it's known for that you act a
[__] ass on that [__] and you don't
realize it
you seem normal to yourself everybody
else you seem real aggressive
you start picking on weaker guys
like an animal you're trying to force
them out of the damn breeding population
big jacked dudes who are aggressive you
love them you can Vibe with them but
anybody who's not so you start
acting bad
um
because you can
so you
yeah you were saying some crazy [__]
this weekend yeah you were saying some
crazy [__] yeah
so I don't really reckon the thing is is
you say crazy [__] you don't really feel
it that much it's uh and I'm telling you
you're saying crazy [__] and then you
just said crazy your [__] and then you
got mad at me yeah yeah and I was like
yeah you don't really take it seriously
when you're saying it it's just like
[__] talking
because it's emotion
so but I don't recommend Tran this is
why I drink
I'm not gonna do it that's not the only
reason I'm not gonna do that one I've
got lots of reasons to drink I'm not
gonna do that again
I recommend more like NPP natural
propionate new look in that one and test
it's a lot easier on you
doesn't make you [__] crazy yeah
because Trend was not meant for human
use really it was for cattle
it's cheap and highly effective and it
works fast I mean I would work out like
crazy you can just [__] work out like
crazy you're strong as [__] and you just
grow but it's mostly shape it's not so
much size as [__] can you just eats all
the fat off you it's beautiful great fat
loss that's that's really why I was
using it just to lose weight lose fat
you know I actually lost weight on it
I'm looking bigger but I lost weight I
lost about 10 pounds
it doesn't look like it but I did
because it was all fat
I'm just saying don't anymore yeah don't
make me have to like dark you no you
know what I mean
again I gained what I could gain from
that one there are other ones that are
safer and cheaper not cheaper soon safer
more expensive and take longer but
they're just more pleasant they're a lot
more pleasant they're more they're more
for human use you know
Tran was an experiment
don't do it don't do it don't do it no
it's not worth it
it's not worth it yeah or at least be by
yourself yeah and not have somebody else
around like having to put up with your
ass actually no no most of my real crazy
[__] thinking happened when I was by
myself then I get around other people
and it would start talking and it would
kind of alleviate and go away
you know what I mean because you'll
you'll start thinking everybody's
talking about you you know what I mean
people plot you get paranoid yeah I
remember that you get real paranoid yeah
you were getting yeah you were you were
alone yeah but then when you start
talking to other people you realize
you're tripping yeah yeah big time so it
doesn't really stick with you but you
but you get real flip it with people
you know like I don't know get out of
here you're like that yeah yeah I know
what you looking at that kind of [__]
you look at me or you want to look at me
yeah yeah I'm [__] driving a car
you're getting like taxi dude looking at
me like what the [__] you looking at me
for you know like he's like bro chill
out he didn't know he just looked away
he's like I was just looking over there
at them
chill yeah yeah
this is why I try to like just keep
ahead when I'm driving I don't want
anybody thinking I'm looking at that
yeah but you'll come off of it and you
think you're all right still
but it seems to have taken me about
three weeks to actually recover from
that cycle I'm still a little [__]
crazy yeah and I know I'm crazy though
now
before I didn't even know I was crazy
yeah
that's good yeah Ben said by the way I
saw a cocaine bear it is amazing see it
on the big screen if you can I've been
hearing a lot about that it sounds kind
of fun
the bear gets Wild on cocaine and starts
racing around the park killing people to
try and get more of the bags bags of
coke Smugglers dropped out of a plane
based our true story that'd be awesome
yeah it's at the theater I like to see
that with a gorilla cocaine gorilla
imagine if a [__] gorilla I'm I'm
imagining Asylum will probably do a
knockoff of cocaine
cocaine bear versus cocaine gorilla
versus religious versus cocaine
alligator
[Laughter]
oh yeah okay
I do I do kind of want to see cooking it
looks like it looks super fun
but uh but yeah all right so we will be
back on Wednesday uh for the main show
as I said it's gonna be about Billy
Milligan the dissociative identity
disorder
rapist guy uh that they talked about on
Netflix so yeah and hopefully I'll get a
chance to watch the rest of it I watched
half of the series but there's two
episodes left so I gotta watch one
tonight and then one tomorrow night so
we'll see her so I can get caught up on
that but uh yeah so thank you very much
for dropping by and hanging out hanging
out with us talking about ghosts and
whatnot remember to like and share and
comment and all that other kind of stuff
for the algorithm and we will see you
guys again on Wednesday good night